qu'est ce qui a déclenché les polémiques
autour de david beckham un bisou sur la
bouche
il est largement présent sur les réseaux
sociaux david mais la dernière photo
qu'il a postées avec sa fille harper
fait polémique puisque c'est la deuxième
fois qu'ils jouent sur l'argument la
première fois et c'était déjà pas
attaqué et il y va y continuer les vols
qui l'assumé il assume exactement
regardée une nouvelle fois c'est un acte
pour le moins anodin qui a divisé les
internautes suite à un geste affectueux
de david beckham envers sa fille si le
footballeur est très proche de ses
quatre enfants il n'hésite pas à montrer
en public des marques d'affection
décomplexée envers ses progénitures
mais chez les beckham comme il est
coutume dans le faire dans certaines
familles quand les enfants sont jeunes
ils embrassent leur parente sur la
bouche une pratique choquante pour
certains internautes qui avaient réagi
une première fois lorsque le footballeur
avait publié une photo avec sa fille
harper huit ans qui l'embrassé sur la
bouche suite à cette polémique
il avait réagi j'ai été élevé comme ça
et c'est comme ça qu'on est avec les
enfants victoria et moi on veut montrer
à nos enfants notre amour et on les
protège on veille sur eux on les
soutient et ce déferlement
d'incompréhension ne semble pas avoir
affecté la star qui a riposté il ya
quelques jours une nouvelle photo sur
laquelle il embrasse là encore sa jeune
fille si certains trouvent ça trop
mignon pour d'autres ce comportement est
inapproprié cette fois-ci david beckham
n'a pas réagi à la polémique
ouais alors voilà donc et il assume
david beckham voilà les amoureux il a
raison il faut assumer
les prochaines réponse au débat sa
petite amie c'est mon ressenti à 14 en
foot ils arrêtent un voile a voulu
écrire est ok merci